the new age of space tourism has been
another giant leap for greenhouse gas
pollution even the water vapor released
by william shatner's ride with blue
origin can result in global warming when
it's released into the upper atmosphere
virgin galactic and soon spacex release
huge amounts of carbon dioxide too all
to give the privileged few a taste of
weightlessness and a spectacular view of
the planet
it's an indictment on the efforts we're
trying to make and you sort of it
undermines us making sacrifices here on
on earth to make sure that we mitigate
the impact that we're having on the
environment and then rich billionaires
are flying out into space for very
expensive selfies
a long-haul air flight typically emits
between one and three tons of carbon per
passenger a rocket launch can result in
between 200 and 300 tons of carbon
dioxide or 50 to 75 tons per astronaut
but as well as carbon dioxide there are
[ __ ] particles chemicals and other
polluting gases released into the upper
atmosphere where they do more damage
they not only trap heat but they trigger
a chain reaction that ultimately
depletes the ozone layer our protective
shield against uv radiation
not all space missions are equal you
could argue tourism is a little
frivolous but the new space age has
brought us a better understanding of our
perilous position on earth
there's the image of our tiny blue
marble that gave liftoff to the
environmental movement many more showing
the astonishingly thin band of the
atmosphere protecting us from the void
of space and the observations of
shrinking arctic ice that have rung
alarm bells
there's this notion called the overview
effect where people who fly at high
altitudes or see the earth from space
really have a sort of changed moment in
their lives where you see the fragility
of earth hanging in the blackness of
space and as we start to see more
regular-like folks going to space and
experiencing this
that it really has the chance to
increase our environmental consciousness
within the next few months spacex is due
to take private astronauts into orbit
needing even more rocket fuel to break
free of gravity
these are early days for the space
tourism industry but virgin galactic
alone is aiming for 400 flights a year
the carbon footprint of billionaires
taking the ultimate sightseeing trip is
about to go stratospheric
thomas more sky news